you need to ask yourself if you're in
the right place a lot of us get into
life and take a path because our
families wanted us to take that path or
there was some societal expectations you
know and that's tough because if you're
not committed in your heart to what
you're doing it's going to be a struggle
a lot of professors take on a different
Persona when they're standing in front
of a classroom it can be intimidating
for students but then you go and start
talking to them in their office they got
pictures of their family they've got
kids they got their dog and all that
stuff so you get to know that they're
human beings too and and you as a human
to human you can form a bond and get to
know each other better what general time
management tips do you have for students
so they can they can keep getting their
A's
believe Nation I have a super exciting
new guest to the channel his name is
nakshine he's got an awesome book The
Ultimate Guide for making top grades in
college the most concise guide it's true
it's 55 Pages uh for your college
success what most excellent students do
to get A's walk my board man
thank you thank you Evan nice to see him
in video person so this is interesting
because my audience is entrepreneurs and
and we haven't really talked about
getting A's in school and how to do it
uh so my hardcore audience might be like
what is this interview all about but I
was excited to have you on for two
reasons one we do have some some younger
people who are on who are in school high
school University and trying to figure
out how to do better in school and also
what I in going through the book
realizes this is actually a book about
learning and can be applied to even
outside the school system because as
entrepreneurs it's a it's a
self-education journey that you're on
and I think a lot of entrepreneurs never
did well in school uh and they're
struggling to learn which will hurt them
it's not that they were necessarily bad
students or or dumb or not smart they
just never actually learned how to learn
which this book kind of teaches you how
to learn so does that resonate does that
sit well with you it does it does you
know I I never thought of myself as one
of those smart students and you know
here I am with a PhD and worked in
Academia for you know 20 something years
but
um what I realized is that
you got to persevere and you got to
break down the system you gotta go at it
with an attitude of this is what I'm
committed to doing which is a lot of
entrepreneurs have to do that right and
uh and then what do I have to do to
prepare what do I have to do while I'm
doing it and what do I do after I get
through a failure I don't call it
failure it's a learning experience and
and then how do I learn from that and
how do I make myself uh do something
better next time so I think life is a
learning process and we are all going
through it and at many times we have
challenges and we feel like we failed
but we haven't failed we're learning and
that's that's the number one message I
want people to have you know it's it's
all positive I love it so you're talking
about uh you have a before during after
methodology which which we'll dive into
a little bit later on but you see the
number one issue with college students
that they never learned how to study
they're putting a lot of effort in but
they don't get the results they wanted
which is the grade so
to the person who's trying and trying
and trying and trying to learn and they
feel like they just can't get it what
are some of the shifts that they need to
make so they can get the results they're
looking for
well number one is a mindset I you know
you need to ask yourself if you're in
the right place
um you know a lot of us get into life
and take a path because our families
wanted us to take that path or there was
some societal expectations and you know
and that's tough because if you're not
committed in your heart to what you're
doing
um it's going to be a struggle uh you
know on inside of yourself you're
fighting with yourself
um so number one is mindset you want to
make sure that uh you're committed to
what you're doing you know why you're
there why is it you're studying a
particular topic and then start breaking
it down how do you prepare for class
what do you do before you go to class
and then what do you do during class
what do you do after a class you know
this is what we do for meetings you
prepare for a meeting you know what you
do during meeting after a meeting you'd
recap you try to figure out what you
learned and and and how are you going to
use the material you learn it's the same
same stuff right I've just taken it and
broken it down into individual items
that are applicable to school this could
be High School uh you know or college
doesn't matter I mean it's it's just
breaking it down saying
hey you're going to go to class there
are certain things you need to do before
you go to class so that you're prepared
for receiving the material and then
during the class
you need to be engaged you need to ask
questions don't be intimidated by your
professor you know you're there it's
like a team effort you know he or she is
there to help you and you're there to
learn and you're going to work together
a lot of students get so intimidated by
professors I had this issue with my own
kids you know Professor is not gonna
scare you away go ask questions you know
um so and then after you get out of
class you know there are certain things
you need to do you need to go over your
notes you need to make sure that you
learn the material how do you know you
learn the material try to teach it to
somebody else
um you know find a friend or somebody
who's willing to study with you and and
try to teach them what you thought you
learned that day and then see if you do
an effective job teaching someone else
something is the best way to learn it I
love it so I was a I was a pretty good
student I got a full scholarship out of
high school to college a University of
Toronto and in there I finished with a
three seven something GPA so you know
not top of my class but still decent but
I feel like if I had read your book that
would have been an easy four afterwards
this is 55 pages but the amount of
things that you've kind of crammed into
55 pages is actually quite impressive uh
you talk about attendance being the
number one indicator of success which is
interesting because I think a lot of
people think well how gifted are they
how smart are they what natural
abilities they have like no it's like do
you show up is the number one indicator
of if they have success or not and I
think that's it's true in life too you
know for any kind of learning you could
just buy this book cool but if you don't
show up and read it you're not going to
get any learning from it why do people
join a class or buy a book and then not
show up you know people have all kinds
of reasons uh and some of it is valid I
mean people struggle life can be hard uh
going to college is not always easy not
everyone has all the finances worked out
people have to work uh sometimes they're
working until midnight and then the next
day they got a class at 8am
well you know when you're exhausted you
kind of feel like ah I'm gonna give
myself a break I'm going to sleep
um so I tend to err on the side of
giving people the benefit of the doubt
but
you know it and they talk themselves
into thinking I don't need to be there
my body is there he'll take notes for me
and uh you know or I'll copy the notes
from somebody else or the lectures are
online I'm just going to look at those
but that you're missing on that
interaction piece you know the part
where you're in class you're engaged
you're talking to the professor you're
asking specific questions because they
help you understand better not the
questions that your buddy asked because
that helped him or her understand the
material better but you need to be there
to ask your questions and to find out
you know there's so much just
communicated through body language and
you know by just reading the material
well you might as well read the textbook
and think oh I got it you know but it
doesn't work that way you need to be
there you need to engage you need to
talk to the professor don't talk
yourself into thinking I don't need to
go to class I I know it's hard but you
gotta get there and if you paid all that
money we both know how much debt people
are accumulating right it's one of the
biggest
um you know things that's going on right
now with college education we don't I
don't I mean my kids got out of school
with debt I I wasn't happy about that
right and I won't I don't want other
people to get out of school with debt
and and then at the same time not get
their money's worth I mean that's that's
really like paying for a product and
then putting it aside saying well I'm
not going to use it
what's great about that is just it's
just the effort
and and that's always controllable like
you can't control where you're born or
who your parents are or how much money
you have or even maybe your natural DNA
or smarts but you're saying the number
one success indicator is just effort
like anybody can always show up that
doesn't discriminate uh and so it's
great to see that that and I think that
translates definitely into the business
world and entrepreneurial success too
like you just got to show up every day
and it's it's not often it you can be
the smartest person and still not be a
great entrepreneur because you just
didn't show up so it's great to see that
that's the number one success factor
um tying into that you talk about
getting early sit at the front
so get into class early and sit in the
front and I just came back from an event
in San Diego and uh I went to go see one
of the speakers and the front seats are
the VIP seats like the front seats are
the most expensive seats right and if
you go to a sporting event or a concert
the front seats are always the one that
people pay more money to but for
whatever reason you know in College
University High School even
you pay the same amount to get into the
university class but all seats are equal
and nobody wants to sit at the front
even though it's like the richest
experience so I mean what are your
thoughts on that why are people not
sitting at the front and and how does it
help people learn better
you know it's a vulnerable feeling uh to
be upfront and so close to the
instructor I I think there's a feeling
of being intimidated by instructors so
people tend to distance themselves a
little bit they want to put this little
space between themselves or maybe
putting other people in between
themselves and and the instructor
um and you know that hurts them because
when you're up front you you're not
going to get distracted you know uh it's
the only thing you can see as an
instructor whatever he or she is doing
the stuff that's going on on the board
or on the projector screen that's what
you got to pay attention to and the the
um sense of false security that you get
by sitting back
um it kind of actually deters from your
experience because now you know your
your attention could waver a little and
then you know your phone buzzes and you
look at it down there under your table
and you're like you're distracted you're
not paying complete attention and and
that's like you said you know you pay
good money to go to a concert you go pay
good money to go to a conference and you
why wouldn't you sit up front and it's
it's amazing because
the um
students who sat up front uh in in my 26
years of teaching at University
um
I would say nine out of ten
were the highest grade students in the
class
and there were students also who sat up
front who were struggling and I
respected them so much because they were
there and they were exposing their own
struggle in class to their classmates
but they allowed me to try to help them
and that's why I was there I'm there to
teach I'm there to help our students
learn the material and these students
were actually working with me it's like
a team effort right and it seemed like
the students who were sitting up front
were the ones who were more engaged and
were would have this back and forth you
know you I say something and I look at
one guy's face and I can tell oh this
really didn't go across all right let me
try it another way you know and and I
think that's really important and some
of the lecture classes nowadays are so
huge
um students get lost and and they don't
really get the good experience I don't
like those kinds of uh lecture rooms
where you got like 500 people and and uh
it's I know some colleges they can't
help it you know that's that's the fact
of life these days but uh you can get
there early and get up front man do it
it's going to help you it's going to
help you understand the material better
it's going to help you engage with the
professor better and you'll get better
grades you know we talk about grades and
grades are one measure
um and I don't want to just put all the
focus on the grade you know because
the biggest thing is that you take away
an understanding of the material you
understand the fundamentals you can
assemble it together assemble the
concepts together in a different way if
you need to and those come from being
engaged looking at it's almost like
you're looking at a let's say you're
looking at a Rubik's Cube and you're
looking at different angles as you look
at it in different angles and different
perspectives you get much better
understanding of the material that's
what we need to do in college
I remember in my first year at
University of Toronto the accounting
class was one of the biggest classes on
campus it was like 1500 students in the
class and in a giant Auditorium three
levels of of seating Stadium style
seating and I did not like accounting
was not my best subject so I struggled
to stay focused compared to other
subjects and I remember when I when I
started I sat at the back because I I
didn't you know I didn't like the
content and I was really struggling just
to pay attention to see the screen the
people around me were just making jokes
and not paying attention either so now
it's easy to fall into that Circle so I
made a ship I mean I didn't I didn't
have this book at the time it's like
okay I need to I need to focus because I
need to get a decent Mark in this in
this class and so get there early start
up front paid attention force myself and
again it's it's just it's controllable
it's just you can get there early and
you can sit up front you don't have to
be a genius to sit up front there's no
there's nobody blocking you there's no
VIP access or ticket you have to buy
like it's just controllable so both of
these like show up the class and sit up
front are completely inside your control
you know what I have put in my book is
simple stuff
you know they say life in life there are
many pieces of advice you receive that
are simple but not easy and and so
that's this is one of those things these
are simple I you could actually do them
no matter what you're doing and
um sometimes people make it more
difficult for themselves but yeah this
is
you know uh
followed advice simple stuff just do
these steps you tell a story in the book
of a one of your students who was
falling asleep in class at the back and
you you know slowly move towards him
keep talking he's still passed out and
then eventually you know his buddy
nudges him and he says hey you know wake
up and and then you are you know say hey
if you want to sleep you could sleep at
home and he's tell some kind of joke
like you know I like sleeping in class
that when everybody laughs but uh how do
you like what would your message to him
be I mean it's a fun it's a fun joke in
the moment makes everybody laugh but I
mean he missed out on the entire lecture
you have a point that if you're going to
sleep just stay home
what would your advice be to somebody
who's always coming in late and sleeping
at the back and struggling to stay you
know attentive and their grades are
really struggling think about it this
way you went to a store you paid this
expensive product and then you put it on
the side of your house and you didn't
touch it
it's the same thing you've paid this
expensive tuition you came to class and
then what did you do you did what you
would do at home you you slept or you
didn't pay attention
um you're wasting your money you know I
I never mind what your parents think
about that but you know you're wasting
your money you're wasting your time and
time is money and entrepreneurs know
that right we're we you know we're
looking at our time and thinking hey I'm
making so much money and uh this my time
per minute is worth this much money and
I need to use this time effectively I
think students need to be looking at
um their time as worth a lot more than
what how they value it
um I think it comes down to looking at
your life and looking at how am I
spending my time what am I doing with my
my my life my time and uh you know using
it more effectively
I have to tell you
the most
focused students uh I had were the
students who had already served in the
military and now they came back to
school and
um they were trying to get their degree
these people were focused they were
disciplined
they knew their time was worth money
they knew how valuable their time was at
school and they used it most effectively
man I admired these people you know some
of them were struggling with all kinds
of
issues
but they would show up they would be
there early and they would do their work
I wish every student did that because
they would all succeed yeah and if I
think about the entrepreneurial world
too how many Zoom conferences are we on
how many virtual trainings are we
attending you may not be going to
University for classes anymore but we're
still learning and attending conferences
and seminars and so what's equivalent
we'll show up early you know we're doing
this over Zoom we were both here early
you know you're you're in your dog food
it wasn't like oh I'm sorry I'm five
minutes late that was like five minutes
early for the session right so if you're
going to trainings show up early turn on
your camera it's the equivalent of
sitting up in the front row as opposed
to if it's off you can you can sleep you
could be browsing something else and not
really paying attention right so I think
it's super applicable I mean as it
sounds basic but I never even thought
about it that way and so
you've been through it so many times you
you were a professor for so many years
you've seen it and so it's you know all
these little life hacks are great in the
book
um one surprising one uh maybe my
favorite was get to know your professor
ah and so that's a little deeper in on
the book but like get to know your
professor and I don't know that I ever
made a conscious effort to get to know
my professor talk about why that's
important and how would we do that when
I might feel weird or awkward to like
how do we get to know our professor you
know a show about office hours
um and and and try to uh use the
resource number one you don't want to
waste your time you want to show up and
and ask questions or you know things
that you're not sure about things that
you didn't learn well enough in class uh
questions that came up for you later you
show up at officers and and talk to them
and no matter what you do it's it's a
human to human interaction no matter
what you do there'll be some side thing
that will come up something about you
know you might be wearing your band
uniform and the professor will say oh
you're in band oh you know what you know
where are you at the game you know
what's going on so I don't get to know
you they want to know you no Professor
goes to teaching profession thinking I'm
going to teach a bunch of robots and I'm
just going to go to class deliver my
material and then go home
that's not what gives us satisfaction we
want to get to know our students there
are so many students that I got to know
over the years and I loved it you know
and and then I we had this relationship
because I could see them in one class
and I could see how they struggled and
how they overcame that struggle and how
we work together to help them pass the
class and then they're taking another
class and and you know what's going on
there and how are you dealing with these
issues now you know you start getting to
know students and and then you're there
I I try to be there at the graduation
ceremony where the faculties sit on the
stage and we watch the students come
through
it is the happiest day of my life you
know watching them graduate and and
you're just you know you have this Bond
I I know you can't have that with every
student but
um I think you end up developing that
with many students I've been blessed
that I got to know so many wonderful
people so many young people
there are some of my best friends we
have lunch every once in a while
nowadays and and it's just
um amazing how these young people have
grown they got their own kids now their
vice presidents directors of companies
but we still know each other from back
when uh they were in school and what did
they do they came to my office we
chatted they talked about what they were
struggling with and gradually we formed
a bond and and that's really important
you know when they were looking for
their first job
I was more than happy to write a
reference letter for them or answer
phone calls somebody calls and says do
you know this this student thing yep I
do and I can tell you they were in every
class they were asking questions they
were engaged and I think they will do a
great job for you as a you know an
engineer in my case
um so I I think going and meeting with
your professors is really important plus
you get to see them as human beings you
know it's a lot of professors take on a
different Persona when they're standing
in front of the classroom uh and and you
know it can be intimidating for students
but then you go and start talking to
them yeah then in their office they got
pictures of their family they got kids
they got they got their dog and all that
stuff so uh you get to know that they're
human beings too and and you as a human
to human you can form a bond and get to
know each other better
what I loved is you had a couple pages
in there basically putting you yourself
in the shoes of the professors like
understand that professors are here to
teach and they want to see you grow and
learn and they could have a job in
corporate world and be making 50 100 you
know more money but they're here why
because they wanna they wanna teach them
I never even thought about like now as a
42 year old man I can kind of think back
but
back when I'm 19 20 I'm like okay I need
to get my grades I need to understand
what's on the test like I'm not even
thinking of this person as a human
just like kind of the guy who's gonna
help me get my grades to get to the next
step but like just asking those
questions uh you've got a couple Pages
I'm like do this and don't do this when
you're going in to talk to your
professor and I think it makes a huge
difference and all those extra bonuses
and connections and the relationship you
know how do you pick the ones who you
perform the relationship well it's the
ones who show up right if you got 500
students in a class that you know you're
not you're not going to go out of your
way probably to always go to the back
row and talk to the person back there if
they're not showing up for themselves so
again it's just an effort thing if
you're showing up you're going to office
hours it creates that opportunity to
create the connection
um yeah yeah so that was one of the
suggestions in the book too of hey show
up to office hours and I remember going
and I I uh at the beginning of my
semester I didn't want to waste time I
didn't want to waste professor's time
like I don't know I'm gonna ask I don't
want to waste time
um there's probably a lot of people
there and he had uh twice a week office
hours for an hour and a half or two
hours and I remember I showed up one
time and nobody was there
it's like wow we've got like 500
students in this class and nobody went
to ask for help at all right right it's
like that's that was shocking I thought
I'd be standing in line for an hour and
like might get one question and nobody
was there at all is that common like are
students just not showing up to office
hours and like teachers are there they
want to serve and help and like nobody's
showing up yeah a lot of times that's uh
that's a fact of life and it's sad
um and and you know what happens then uh
there's the exam day and then all of a
sudden there's this line uh by the
professor's office saying you know hey
uh what do I do about this what do I do
about that but
um it you know again it's just like
anything else in life look ahead you got
to prepare and you know you don't you
know overcome a huge obstacle by just
you know dealing with it on the last
step you break it down you deal with it
at every step and so you need to go talk
to your professor and Professor is there
I mean in many schools they're obligated
to be there for that hour and a half
that you mentioned right so
they they would love to have somebody
stop by their office and talk to them
and
you know the thing is when as a
professor I heard a student ask me a
question
the question gave me an insight to how
they were analyzing the topic and did I
communicate it the best way possible
there were many times when they left my
office I took some notes and I told
myself the next lecture I'm going to go
back and talk about this topic again and
talk about it in this different way
so I think it's really important yeah I
it's unfortunate that people don't show
up at office hours and take advantage of
this resource that's available to them
you know it's like you have a professor
in class but you're sharing the
professor with another 500 people but
now you can you could have a professor
uh all to yourself
and and you could ask whatever you want
uh why wouldn't you take advantage of it
yeah but people get scared and and
that's something that I you know I kept
talking to students but you need to
overcome that you can't be intimidated
by especially freshmen you know freshmen
go into school and they're like oh my
God you know these professors they're
like you know gods and I I can't go
waste their time and I can't ask
questions but you can that's what
they're there for and they want to be
there for you yeah or they just don't
know I mean I think when I started I
just didn't know I wasn't used to that
in high school that wasn't something
that teachers did so it just wasn't part
of my How I Learned or that what was
trained into me so like oh this is an
option okay I think the week before the
exam definitely is when people start
coming but then also the week after the
tests come back and and fighting over
the grade like why did I get a B minus
instead of an a you know and and and
that's probably the worst time to go and
talk to Professor when everybody's just
complaining about their grades or
stressed out about the exam coming up
ahead so to your point just being able
to go connect with them on their office
hours makes a huge difference
um there was one one it's a relationship
building you're building a relationship
and as entrepreneurs we know how
important that is you could you don't go
out there and make a product a high
quality product and say here I'm going
to throw it out at customers and then
buy and then leave you know you build a
relationship that's how you develop you
develop your business and this is the
same thing
in my third year of University I went
and built a relationship with one of my
professors and saw him on his office
hours and he proposed to me that in my
fourth year we do a I forget what he
called it it's like a self-study course
or we just designed our own course
together where he sponsored my course
that we did on on pricing a product and
I had no exam no tests I just had to
meet him once a week and kind of talk
about what I had learned so I was
getting free mentorship from him with no
exam at the end of it like this is great
I wish I had I didn't even know this was
an option I wish I found this out sooner
all because I just went and talked to my
professor on his office hours when
nobody else was showing up
yeah and that's part of being engaged
you know there are many options to get
your degree
um there are a lot of little loopholes
um uh you know doing some kind of an
independent research with your professor
is one of those options but unless you
talk to your advisor you talk to your
professor uh you know not every
Professor want to do it independent
research with you uh because maybe
you're an interest don't line up but uh
talking and building a relationship you
can find all those resources and you'll
have a much better experience I bet that
independent study work or independent
research work you did ended up being an
amazing experience for you in hindsight
plus the fact that you got to know this
professor so well uh on one-on-one basis
yes basically once a week I'd go in and
get free mentorship
you know he would teach me and train me
about pricing because I knew nothing
about pricing I cared about it and
launched my business and the idea that I
didn't have to study for an exam was
also great to me at the time and it was
one of those hacks that I wish I knew
earlier I didn't know professors can
sponsor you to do one-on-one studies and
that counts as a credit for your that's
that was fantastic I only knew that
because I showed up and I was the only
one coming at the office hours so the
professor has to like you they're
obviously not going to do that for most
students but again if nobody's showing
up and nobody's sitting on the front and
nobody's you know coming out to office
hours it's not actually not that hard to
stand out in a professor's eye right
exactly exactly you know even students
who struggle uh even the struggle is
part of getting to know each other
um I'll tell you a story
um I had this older student and he was
struggling he was struggling with taking
exams he would understand the material
but taking exams was a tough thing for
her and I think he had a lot of exam
anxiety ready and at one time I remember
thinking to myself I need to start the
exam day with some meditation music or
something and calm these students down
but you know in engineering that people
would have had a fit you know to doing
something like that so anyway
um
he would come to my office we would have
these discussions and then there would
be that day where there's this long line
out of my office and people are asking
questions and he's somewhere you know
halfway through the line and um as I'm
answering questions I watch and I see
other students are showing up in the
line and this guy's answering their
questions and they're leaving
and you know it just made me feel like I
want to help this student so much more
because he deserves it you know he
obviously this is something he's he's
challenged with and I need to help him
with that and I did you know we we
worked together we try to get him help
and and
um you know in a lot of schools there's
um office of uh student Disability
Services you know things like that that
students don't even know about you know
they don't
if you've been the same way all your
life you have no idea if this is
different from other people
and so
um yeah you know there's there's a lot
that a professor can do for you yeah
this is a story I don't know if it's
true or not but when Rescue helicopters
show up to uh you know those people
drowning and they only have like one one
life fast there's only certain amount of
space in a helicopter it's like well who
do you pick to take with you and the
answer was well it's the one who swim to
the helicopter right it's like there's
only a little bit a little amount of
space like show that you're interested
in being saved show up it's not that
difficult but put in the effort right
right and just like in life there are
many people who are struggling and in
school you have the same group of people
you know there's people who
um you know they go through a bad
breakup they're people who are having
depression issues family members die you
know it's just it it's real life and it
happens in school too and there are a
lot of resources at universities for
helping these people
um you know a lot of people don't even
know that you know if something drastic
happens in your life you can go to your
professor you can go to your
um you know the head of your school and
you can get a lot of exemptions uh but
people are so afraid to ask these
questions they just go away and they get
take the bad grade and you know if your
school knows about it they want to help
you
um so make sure you approach them make
sure you ask people for help anytime
you're struggling with anything
you also talk about the importance of
forming a study group and this is where
I probably struggled the most is I tried
to do everything myself and if I was
going back I would have tried to me
maybe because I'm introverted or shy
just okay I'm gonna do it myself or I
had some bad experiences and study
groups I'm just going to do it on myself
but I recently came across a quote from
Bill Gates who was talking about
education and formal education says the
number of students who can learn without
a social setting is very very small it's
like so we learn collectively where if
you're left to your own devices all by
yourself you're probably not going to
pick up the material so can you talk
about the importance of forming study
groups and how do we go about making
that happen
absolutely
um you know in a lot of schools as
you're going through your degree program
you'll see the same students kind of
moving along with you and maybe they're
not in every class but you guys are all
advancing at about the same rate and you
know people can form friendships and
it's it's wonderful if you can start
with one person and then ask another
person but gradually
um form a group where you guys can come
together and I say this I try to make
this very clear you're not there to copy
homework from each other but and there's
so much value in having another person
explain to you the concept that you just
saw in class the way they saw it we we
all see the material in a different way
and
um learning to see it from different
points of view different perspectives
it's so valuable and when you teach it
to somebody else this is how I
understand of the material this is what
I learned from the material it is so
much more valuable
I got so much value out of the group of
people I studied with when I was an
undergraduate student there was a group
of us and we would all show up at the
school library and they had a study area
I will you know
put your books down and we're there to
do our work and somebody gets stuck hey
did you understand this any better I
didn't understand this topic and that
person gets the chance to try to teach
you this is helping them as well and and
then as time went on you know as I went
to graduate school
I had other people who I was working
with and hey it's time for me to go to a
conference and give a presentation would
you mind listening to my talk and
critiquing it
would just chew it to shreds and I I was
grateful for that because now I was
prepared for anything and everything so
there's so much value in working with
other people to learn to prepare uh for
what you know whatever it is that you're
trying to get out of school
if I think backwards to myself you know
20 years ago in college what my two big
things probably would have been
I'm carrying this group you know like
I'm the I'm the one who cares the most I
picked the wrong people and so I don't
want to waste my time and two I'm afraid
to go up and talk to people to say hey
do you want to be my study partner do
you want to inform a study group so what
advice would you have for people who
feel either those two things
I think what you need to think about is
that everybody else is feeling the same
thing
you know right we're all human we're all
human we all have insecurities and we
just cover our insecurities in different
ways uh you know other people might seem
unapproachable uh but hey you put it you
put out an effort you ask a question uh
you don't have to say hey be my best
buddy or you know study together all the
time say hey um I need to understand
this one topic better you seem to ask a
good question in class that indicated
you understand this material better than
I do would you mind if we met after
class I'll buy you a coffee and then you
can you can explain this to me a little
bit better
um I would really appreciate it you know
that's a start you just you know you
kind of get started and see if that's
something that's a
lasting relationship you can continue it
if not then you move on you you try to
form a uh you know a relationship with
working roulette I call these working
relationships you know here in school
but man this is your job you're working
um and so you know gradually you're
going to have a group of people a lot of
times these come together almost
naturally sometimes professors will
assign a project they just put a group
of people together well now you get to
really get to know people and yeah yeah
if you're carrying the whole group yeah
they're probably not good uh study
partners for you in the future
that's knowledge you just gained some
knowledge about you're just eliminating
some people from your possibilities but
there are other people in class who are
they got their hand up or asking
questions they're sitting up front
they're engaged with a professor you
you're watching them uh you know taking
notes
you know those are the kind of people
you want to focus on
what I love about it is it might be
awkward it might be uncomfortable but
it's a fantastic skill to learn because
once you get out into the corporate
world the academic world the
entrepreneurial world you can't do this
alone
right it's like you you can't have
success in any career by yourself and so
if you've just kind of gone through high
school studying and got got good grades
cool but if you are just a loner always
you will never accomplish your big goals
and so uh it's it's great kind of forced
awkwardness to learn the skill uh and I
wish I'd done it sooner because I didn't
figure this out until maybe in my 30s
you know again I wish I had this book
maybe I'm still trying to figure it out
man I don't know
you know but I think that's an important
Journey for people to go on to recognize
hey like I I can't do this alone it's
okay to ask for help whether it's the
professor and showing up the office
hours whether it's forming a study group
a lot of what you're again in like in
reading through the book A lot of it was
that what I was expecting was study
hacks and you do a lot of those but
there's a lot of relationship stuff in
there too that was unexpected which um
again and reflecting back like I wish I
had that knowledge because it makes a
lot of sense going backwards but I
didn't have that knowledge when I was 19
20 21 kind of going through the school
system right right you know life is all
about relationships you're you know the
connections you build with people uh and
again entrepreneurs know that best you
know you can't work in isolation and uh
and and that's it's really important
sooner you learn the better the more
successful you will be
you um you're talking a book about one
of the major mistakes students make is
they don't turn in their homework
and when I read that I was like really
are people not
from work like at all like I mean I
could imagine if you just didn't do a
good job or you didn't understand the
material
but I don't think I I ever just did not
hand something in is that super common
you know for some people it is uh not
everyone but for some people it is uh
just uh you know they're they're looking
at the system and thinking well
you know I I didn't get a chance to do
my homework today and I'll I'll take
care of it another day so they're not
handing in their homework
um it's it's that whole business of
having wrong priorities
um instead of breaking down this big
um Mountain into little rocks and taking
care of them uh they're thinking well
I'll just be ready for the exam well you
won't be ready for your exam if you
didn't break down the topic and learn to
hand in the homework as the material was
being learned so yeah some people do
that uh not you know not all successful
students will do that well nice
successful students will not do that but
it's it's the uh the other people who
are they just want to get by you know
and uh and it's it's tough because uh
um it's it's one of the things that just
like the simple thing we said show up to
class
hand in your homework do your homework
hand in your homework and and it seems
so simple but again some people will
just ignore that wow I think of it as
three stages of of Freedom when you're
going from high school to University or
college to then entrepreneurship where
in high school you're being told what to
do your parents are telling you what to
do the teacher's telling what to do you
know if you don't if you don't hand
something in you know a call goes home
and say hey
Johnny didn't hand this in what's going
on and but then you get to University of
College and you don't have the phone
calls anymore nobody's chasing you down
the professor's not chasing you down and
saying hey hand in your homework or you
have to stay in detention afterwards and
then you get to entrepreneurship there's
nobody at all there's not even a
structure to follow and so it's a great
I I mean I saw a number of my classmates
struggle with that extra Freedom that
they were given because they were used
to having somebody else discipline them
as opposed to them having the
self-discipline to show up and do the
work one of my best friends Almost got
kicked out of the program because he
just was failing so much in the classes
because he wasn't doing it he wasn't
showing up wasn't handing the homework
wasn't studying for the test he had
complete Freedom just partying all the
times like dude come on I need you for
next semester we gotta do this together
um
I think we need to do a better job of
preparing our high school students for
that transition
you know that when you go to college
there's this huge transition as you
mentioned all of a sudden from everybody
telling you what to do to now you have
choices and you have to manage your time
you know it's you know that managing
your time is one of those things that
some people didn't have to do when they
were in high school
um I think we need to do a better job of
preparing our high school students for
that transition when I saw a college
student I looked at him as
this man or woman will be working during
a full-time job somewhere within two to
three years from now and my job is to
treat them like the professional that
they're going to be
and and so what that means is that I
give him the freedom with freedom comes
responsibility and then there's
consequences and and that's what one of
the hardest things that they have to
learn I think parents in in high school
uh administrators could do a better job
of preparing students but you know it's
one of your tips is uh be engaged and
ask questions and
whenever I'm doing a training I always
if I'm doing a training on YouTube how
to grow your YouTube channel uh I tell
people the beginning maybe it's a
two-hour training hey I want you to come
prepared with a question like don't come
and just listen to me talk and take a
bunch of notes but what question if I
answered for you would make a meaningful
impact to the growth of your YouTube
channel
in in a university or a college
environment
would you use that as a rule of thumb
like always ask a question or always be
thinking about a question that during
the middle of a you know whenever we get
the questions I want to ask something
for clarification so that they're more
engaged
absolutely I I don't think
look as a professor standing in front of
a class of 50 100 150 God forbid 1500
there's no way you can present the topic
in a way that everyone can understand it
perfectly
so there's got to be questions there's
got to be people who uh maybe even their
they got a little distracted and they
didn't pay close attention and they
wanted they want me to repeat something
that's okay raise your hand this is your
opportunity you need to raise your hand
and ask a question
and if you didn't understand something
and this was one of the most important
things I got out of my students asking
questions
they ask a question they say you said
I don't understand it and we go back and
forth so which part of it you didn't
understand how did I explain it that you
didn't understand how can I explain it
so that you better understand it and I
think that's what a professor gets out
of you asking questions is what can I do
better how can I explain this topic
better now you asked a question that I
am sure at least 10 other students in
the class had the same question but they
were afraid to raise their hand and you
just did a huge favor for so many other
people in class so I I don't want
students to think like oh I'm taking
class time I'm you know all this stuff
ask your question you didn't understand
something ask your question you're there
to get the material Professor is there
to convey the material and it's a give
and take if you didn't receive it ask
for it in a different way so I think
it's really important
if I think back to my university days or
even now in business conferences
whenever it goes to q a time there's
always this kind of awkward
lull while you're waiting for somebody
to be the first one to ask a question
and then it ends up being there's so
many questions that you don't have time
for it's like well where were you at the
beginning like ask the first question
and so I think you know if you just
meant I'm this is a hack for myself now
but I think it could be useful for
others is I'm preparing myself for
wherever I go to learn I'm gonna I want
to ask the first question
and so in listening to the presentation
I'm already thinking what's my question
going to be so now I'm more engaged in
the content because I'm thinking about
the question and then when whenever they
move the Q a like I got it I'm ready I'm
first I want my question answered let's
go like I think that I can shift and
um
if you apply that to the College
University setting you you well you even
know I mean the material is already laid
out in advance from the textbook
typically it may not be word for word
you may not get through all the material
but you already know enough of what is
going to be taught
so what are your questions like if
you're reading the textbook already with
questions in mind does it shift how you
show up for that lecture day oh
absolutely absolutely no textbook will
explain things in a way that you're
going to understand every little detail
um otherwise you wouldn't need an
instructor why do you need an instructor
if you just you can get it out of the
textbook so uh you know I in my book I I
say that you should look over the
material before you go you go to class
and have some ideas about the things
that you didn't understand and then look
for those in the lecture that the
professors delivering and if you didn't
get it you better have those questions
ready and ask your questions because hey
that's one sure way to get your money's
worth understanding material and leave
the classroom uh having your questions
all answered it's it's like when you go
to a meeting you know you want to be
ready for the meeting what do you want
to get out of the meeting
everybody asks themselves that question
right I'm going to a meeting I'm going
to spend my time in a meeting what do I
want to get out of this meeting and what
are the things that I need to ask and
what are the things I need to get out of
this meeting with same thing you're
doing that before going to class
preparing for it and asking your
questions
you talk about the Golden Rule and uh
and when when you think of the golden
rule I think of Christianity and
religion and the golden rule of doing to
others but you've got your own Golden
Rule uh which applies to studying so
tell us about you know the Golden Rule
and how we can apply it yeah you know uh
a lot of students uh coming making that
transition from high school to
um College they think that all I need to
do is just go to class and uh you know I
think in in some High School classes
they might have devoted some time to
doing some practice problems or homework
and things like that they might not have
a lot of homework at home
um but college is different and and my
rule of thumb always was for every
credit that the course is worth now I'm
also thinking as a semester uh schedule
not a quarter type of uh
College uh for for a semester-long class
for every quarter every credit you need
to spend three hours outside of the
class so we're talking three hours in
class
nine hours outside of class that's a
total of 12 hours that you're spending
each week now you know I'll be honest at
the beginning of the term things are
picking up slow you might not really
need to spend so much time with the
material but there's going to be another
time where you're going to be spending a
lot more than 12 hours on that
particular course so it's an average
it's a rule of thumb that I always use
uh It generally came up because in
engineering at the end of the
four years students have to do a
Capstone project and so you know
basically they're building something
they're doing something on their own and
usually they're working as a group and
you know and they start thinking like
well I can stuff off and I can't really
I don't really need to do a lot of work
well that Capstone project class is
worth
um three credits and I would tell them
look
you're responsible for a minimum of 12
hours of work per you know per week on
this class so that's where it came from
but it really carries throughout the
um the college education that's that's
really the minimum average time that you
need to put in for each class
I love it it's a good rule of thumb and
it ties then to note taking and you
outline
five different ways to take notes and
like there's five ways to take notes
this is amazing I didn't know this uh
you get the Cornell outline mapping
uh sentence and starting Charter
charting all these different methods and
so you quickly outline each one of how
you can take notes and uh you know I
have to review how how I take notes I
wish I knew those methods beforehand I
think the closest for me is maybe the
Cornell method
um what I will typically do is I'll go
with two notebooks so if I'm like now at
42 year old I've been going to a
business event uh I have one notebook
where I'm just taking notes like
anything the person says I'm writing it
down trying to take detailed notes I
know you're a big stickler on like take
detailed notes don't just take like one
quote that they said take detailed notes
and then on the plane ride home I'll
I'll look at the notes and put it into
my second notebook of what do I need to
focus on what I need to prioritize like
how do I apply this right now what are
the main lessons and even looking at it
a second time really helps uh the
Cornell method seems to become maybe the
closest to that where you're you have
your main notes on the side and then
your important notes or summary you know
down the down the columns and at the
bottom
have you and for anybody who wants a
detailed breakdown just go pick up the
book we'll link it up in the description
below it's probably easy this picture is
it shows you how to do all these things
have you found one technique more
effective than the other is it based on
personality or how do I decide which of
the five techniques are best
you know it different techniques work
better for different people uh I use the
sentence method
um and just like you uh kind of like the
variation of what you did
um I I had loose paper that I would take
with me and I'd take notes and then at
night I would go home and I would
rewrite those notes uh maybe sometimes
even with more explanation in a
different uh notebook so uh you know
that way I had everything because in
class I'm taking notes it's fast I you
know it's barely legible in uh you know
going back home then I could you know
rewrite it but I think I used the
sentence method and that worked well for
engineering but there are each of these
techniques is
um might fit better for a different type
of material that you're studying it also
might fit better for a different Pro
person
you know some work better for people
more visual so I would say experiment
um you know there's you try the
different techniques and see which one
works well for you try a different
technique in a different class different
type of class and see which one works
for you
um again just like you said you didn't
know these techniques exist I didn't
know until years after I got my degree
so
um I wish I had known about these
techniques as well but I want students
to know those yeah and I think I think
there's a lot of value in figuring out
which one works for you and in what kind
of situation
that's a great distinction because I was
in reading it assuming oh well there's
one style that's best for me not
necessarily another style might be
better depending on the content that I'm
trying to learn so you know the mapping
technique is a very visual it's like a a
tree org chart kind of thing that you're
working towards and maybe it's a if it's
a really visual concept mapping might be
better than the Cornell technique
um so I like that a different technique
might be better for you in different
situations depending on what you're
learning I'm excited to dive in and try
all these things out this is great
like I'm learning at 42 I'm learning how
to learn again this is this is amazing
hey I'm 61 I'm still learning and and I
love it that's uh I know I'm alive when
I'm learning
you you've touched on time management a
little bit and you know University
students are struggling as a first case
of Freedom they're trying to balance you
know relationships and maybe being away
from home in all the classes and
extracurricular and sports and band and
all the things what what general time
management tips do you have for students
so they can they can keep getting their
A's
you know I I think uh it's really
important to have clear priorities uh
that's where it all starts what are your
priorities in
um I know there are a lot of books that
talk about sit down write down your
goals write down your priorities and I
think there's a lot of value in that
um you know what are the things that you
you want to spend your time on and why
uh I think a lot of times we're on
um Auto uh you know friends say let's go
do this let's go do this you know
somebody else says let's go do this
we'll go do that
um and I think we need to pay attention
to what's important to us and uh how we
can devote our time clearly to our top
priority items I think that's that's the
number one uh factor in uh time
management I don't think there is
shortage of time I think there is
unclear priorities and people people
need to be really clear about what they
want to spend their time on what's been
what's of value to them
but then that you know this time
management can also show itself in other
aspects of our life you hear about
people talking about it I don't have
entrepreneurs I don't have enough time
for my family I don't have enough time
for it this is real I mean these are
demands of life and the sooner we learn
the skill of establishing our priorities
figuring out how we're going to devote
our time to those priorities the more
successful we would be the happier you
will be and I think that's really
important I you know the number one
thing I want to see in my students my
kids for sure
be happy productive people and go on
doing whatever you're going to do but to
be happy you need to make sure that
you're paying attention to those things
that are important to you and to to do
that you need to know exactly what are
the important things you've seen the the
chart with with the
Urgent versus uh important uh the four
quadrants
um that's a that's an excellent example
of uh giving you a way of
analyzing the different situations in
your life and is it important
and is it urgent at the same time that
means you let it become urgent
um so the the better uh way to go about
it is to deal with things that are
important when there have not become
urgent and so that's you know those are
the kind of things that there's a lot of
time management books out there uh the
other place that time management comes
in is in taking exams
um and and I talk about that in my book
because a lot of times people start
taking the exam and they just lose track
of time
um well again
time management there are so many
problems you want to make sure you get
to all of them you got to give yourself
certain amount of time to spend I tell
my students start off looking at each
problem and thinking to yourself how
much time you're going to devote to that
problem
giving yourself some spare time so that
once that you're done one making one
pass through the test you can go back
and review your answers so again it's
another time management hack that you
know it helps you in taking exams but it
all comes down to
figuring out how much time you want to
spend on certain things
I love it I got one last question for
you you open the book and you close the
book talking about self-awareness and
understanding what is your motivation to
even be here in the first place that's
the first thing you talk about and it's
how you end the book too and you
mentioned that yours was security you
really valued security that's why you
went down this path
how do you guide people through figuring
out what their motivation is to be in
college yeah and that's a it's a tough
one because it's a stage of life where
there's a lot of things happening at the
same time
where you're young uh maybe you've never
had to struggle with these questions
um but I think it's really a value to
ask yourself
why am I here at every stage of your
life
no matter where you are how old you are
doesn't matter why am I here
and why am I spending my time at this
particular place doing this specific
activity
um I think it's important for students
to you know there are certain classes at
times that you can take that will make
you think about some of these topics
there's a lot of general education
classes that students have to take no
matter what your major is and I think
there's a lot of value in those I know a
lot of schools or professors sometimes
even will pooh-poo some of those classes
but I think there's a lot of value and
you know taking a psychology class
taking a Sociology class thinking about
some of these topics and hopefully those
professors in those classes are making
the students think about these bigger
questions
reading is the number one activity that
helped me uh I think I was a Avid Reader
from my youth and you know I read as
much as possible and don't discriminate
read all kinds of different things yeah
I think it opens your mind to
possibilities and makes you think more
about where you want to go and and what
you want to do like I said I'm still
learning I I think it's a lifelong
process and uh and we all need to keep
at it do you have any quick book
recommendations apart from your own well
we'll link this up any any quick book
recommendations that you think every
college student should read I would say
there are some resources in the back of
that book there are some good books uh
available that delve much deeper into
the different topics that I talked about
you mentioned note-taking there's
specific books that address note-taking
by itself I'd say my book gives you a a
top menu and then dig into some of some
of these topics more detail and and
there's resources in the back use those
as a starting point but yeah keep keep
learning
I love it well this is what it looks
like everybody it's called The Ultimate
Guide for making top grades in college
we'll link it up in the description
below thank you for spending time with
us sharing your knowledge and best of
luck with the book launch
thank you
to see my one-on-one with crochet's
son-in-law Alex hermosi check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there people will hate you for who
you are more so because of what it makes
them feel about themselves the strategy
of what I do is make stuff that is
really valuable to people from in the
trenches experience that is happening in
real time right now